i never take it for granted it's an
honor to do a game that jacob legram
pitches every fifth day remember he left
after six innings in his last start six
shutout innings
and he's gonna go right back to the
slider and he gets peterson for the
first down of the night and there's your
first strikeout out of the strike zone
garrett the back back foot slider he
needs that low and away slider that
has just been responsible for so many of
his strikeouts and there it is and
against baez
two strikeouts in the opening inning for
the grom
slider's gonna play a big role here
early in the game yep
and he goes right back to the slider and
gets the strikeout now he's fanned three
of the first four hitters he gets half
on the back foot slider just on right on
the side of that ball the first inning
that slider was a little bigger and it
was a little slower but this ending back
to that real hard spinning slider son
you keep moving that glove it tells me
it's a ball so if i were you i'd just
leave it right there
2-2
and he struck him out
the grom outsmarts wisdom two men down
good pitch there that ball
had cut on it it was cutting away from
wisdom as opposed to coming back towards
the corner take it just five for 33 to
start the year
one for five in his career against the
ground
[Applause]
and he takes strike three call got him
looking at a backdoor slider on the 11th
pitch of the at-bat degrom strikes out
the side in the second
24 consecutive scoreless inning kids
couldn't take advantage of a lead off
walk in the first inning now they get
one in the second and here's pilar
that's driven toward right center field
back in the gap and that'll short hop
the wall racing for third is mckinney
he's going to be waved around bias with
a relay throw to the plate it's cut off
an rbi double for kevin killard gives
the mets a one-nothing lead
up and away fastball
bell time went right with it
and what did the cubs do here
they missed the cutoff man
one thing we've learned about billy
mckinney he does a lot of things well
you can say that about a lot of players
that are playing every day right now
[Applause]
two out and now it's left to degrom to
drive the run in
[Music]
gary was it like this with saber
back in the day
not not his first time up in the game 10
hits on the season
and he rips one and he's got 11. and
that one brings in a run
a hard turn to gromble settle for an rbi
single he is simply amazing
what a great advantage
his 11th hit his sixth rbi two nothing
new york
hitters on the bench are like it's not
that easy
maybe it is it's something special yeah
that was a good pitch
down and in that's where he likes it
oh he's something special that's all
there is to it
i hope that that kid
50 years from now is able to tell his
grandkids that he watched jacob degrom
they know their body better than anyone
and there's something going on right now
i agree yeah i agree with you and it
happened three pitches ago and usually
he gets ready and fires he's kind of
catching his
taking more time and you know jeremy
hefner is keeping a sharp eye on that
and he gets so guard looking at the
slider
six strikeouts through the first seven
batters for degrom
six of the strikeouts have come on the
slider one on the fastball he puts the
hitter away when he throws that slider
47 of the time which is just an amazing
number and he does it again
as he gets low baton and that's six in a
row for degrom and seven of the first
eight
down via the strikeout
one two coming
yep and stock takes a call third strike
three perfect innings for jacob degrom
with eight strikeouts including the last
seven hitters
what a start well his results have been
overwhelming but clearly something was
bothering jacob to grom in that last
inning and when it was over he went
directly down the tunnel
dom hits one of the air to deep right
field backwards ortega near the wall
it's out of here
tom smith cranks his sixth home run of
the year second home run in this series
and it's three nothing new york in the
third
right down the middle mid thigh
dom's wheelhouse fastball right keith
yes
there's a just missed one as he took
mckinney to the wall
rizzo drives that one down the line that
one heading towards the upper deck and
that one is gone
anthony rizzo bless one out
and the cubs are on the board
first hit of the night produces a run
his ninth and it's 3-1
so they've had some productive plate
appearances even without hits with the
bases full
too high ball four and that forces in a
run
the tenth time this year the mets have
drawn a base of loaded walk that brings
in guillermo to make it 4-1
check swing tapper down to first rizzo
steps throws home too late
it'll be an rbi ground out to make it
five to one really the only play rizzo
had
made sure he got smith for the second
out
but nito comes home to make it a 5-1
game
pillar drives one deep to left field
forget that that is way out of here
kevin pallar already with an rbi double
tonight and now he sucks his fifth home
run of the year and it's six to one new
york pilar having a big night at the
plate the men's second home run of the
night
to build a five-run lead
down and in
i think that was a hanging slider
we spent so much time talking about what
a inspiration he is
what toughness he has shown sometimes we
forget to talk he's a darn good baseball
player
[Applause]
that's drilled right field towards the
corner and that one is gone
that one is gone as ortega will touch
them all and a two run homer there
makes it a 6-3 game line shot just over
the wall in right
that was a bullet 1-2 coming
looped into center field pilar coming on
diving he's got it and the ball game is
over
williams makes the catch in center field
and diaz gets the one out he needs for
the save and the mets have taken the
first three of the series from the cubs
as they win this one 6-3
despite the injury to jacob degrom